marino di cipresso miccio che succede
un'altra challenge tra l'amico di parola
nuova sfida per voi challenge nascondino
mi parve natalini tre tumori mia trauma
trinità insomma il turno più ma hai
sentito
dobbiamo giocare il tondino e chi perde
i primi round avrà una penitenza
dell'ultimo round che benitez non lo so
ma comando poi lasciate un bel mi piace
se volete un'altra challenge di
videogiochi nella vita reale la so non
mi piace qua sotto e iniziamo con il
primo round
red due però devo trovare harting a una
10 e poi ti ricorderà un fitto fitto di
nascosto scoprire idea mi nasconderò qui
su quest'albero così la principessa
peach non riuscirà a trovarvi
si no se non fatta ritroverà la
principessa lavoro problema spero di no
mario accordo
vero
sono nascosti proprio bene visto che non
ti ho visto con sopra visto che non c'è
buffon o ci pensa di vaio o no ci ha
visto aiuto chavista voi faccio tessuto
[Risate]
[Musica]
mito preso non mi sono nascosto tanto
bene principessa pizza primo round
questo vuol dire che adesso dovrò
nascondermi di nuovo io che condurrà un
breve nuovamente i nostri gesti mario
speriamo di riuscire a vincere così
evito la penitenza dei pranzo mare a
nasconderti nuova casa ti troverò ho
un'idea chiamo mario dalle finestre e
vediamo dove si nasconde ecco lo vedete
già vinto un bando si sta nascondendo
dietro quell albero ma si vede benissimo
che era tutto lì
pensa davvero di riuscire a nasconderti
dietro l'albero
[Musica]
lo scatto dentro la palma 6 questa
djerba mario sta tagliando l'erba
vabbè andiamo a cercarlo sono sicura che
è nascosto in giardino e probabilmente
lo troveremo subito andiamo a questo
caso non va abbastanza veloce kart mi
sono sbagliato questo non è il gioco
mario kart queste super mario nascondino
nella vita reale o no ho sbagliato mezzo
questo non ti serve devo forza ho
trovato la soluzione verità guardate che
cosa qui un rotolone d'erba e mia rotore
roba dentro con burrito sarà
l'ingrediente speciale questo burrito
c'è nessuno
proseguiamo e adesso vi possono volare
c'è un problema di un problema non
nascondendo aspetta fresco aiuto dove
vorrei che devo trovare una soluzione
per nascondermi meglio
no non è incastrato sono rimasto
incastrato questo tubo d'erba non riesco
più ad uscire da qui trova una soluzione
prima che arrivi la principessa sera
mario forse il tagliaerba ecco il
tagliaerba che sta valutando quindi
forse è qua vicino
vediamo dove sei mario tanto ti trovo
[Musica]
sentito un rumore strano nel rino
aiutami a trovare mario molto strano
visto che mario si nascondeva dietro a
questo albero ma non è più qui forse è
tornato dentro casa e non si sta più
nascondendo qua in giardino o visto
qualcosa di strano laggiù
che cos'è vaglio c'è un pezzo derbali
[Musica]
chakwal quadra che non cosa
sono riuscito a vincere io questo turno
questa volta di un fregata che ti ho
vinto io questo corsara tocca a me
nascondermi bruzzise l'inter sarà un re
o deciso di nascondermi dentro casa
invece che nascondermi in giardino e mi
nasconderò sotto al tavolo
cosa posso fare nomi di 9 10 39 e 40
aver sentito i suoi passi sulle scale
scegliamo andiamo a controllare insieme
[Musica]
strano non sembra esserci forse sia
nascosta bene andiamo a vedere potrebbe
essere qui dove si sono nascosta pc e
devo cercare cerchiamo meglio forse si è
nascosta in questa armadio
[Musica]
[Applauso]
o no comprendo che tu prendi stati
beccati in fretta non ti permettono di
scappare mi ami
quindi tu ribasso sui turni non lo metto
tutor mito e rito sono turno quindi la
penitenza nell'ultimo round memoria di
pane a un corso preparati per la dynit
enza il cappuccio uno che cosa succederà
adesso
che cosa è successo a mio gusto che da
mario o no non riesco a portarli anche i
piedi principessa principessa la
penitenza e di tumore di tipo di stare a
morte di un pc dove mario oggi maria ho
rispettato
mario con lo sputo in faccia nascondersi
con questo costume nord mi metto qui
dietro questi vasi berlino ad hoc che
devo trovare più spazio per nascondervi
con questo costume gigante bene andiamo
a prendere mario principessa
ho anche preso la banana da tirargli
addosso
vedo qualcosa qua ma non è riuscita a
nasconderti per niente questa parte
[Musica]
rimani castrato
fede che si ha fretta
ok
si è alzata
aiutiamo la prima scelta dal sardo anzi
principessa del bicicletta principessa
possano tornare mario è un po
principessa ma quasi funzionato avete
comprato la fame se volete vedere altri
challenge nascondino di supermario nella
vita reale non stati un bel viaggio e
ora cliccate su una di queste quattro
castellina ricca te su quella che
preferite
ciao
[Musica]